PROFESSOR: For these
heritage learners--
I'd say 99% of
them, the students,
the heritage learners in this
course-- they started unevenly.
So it's really hard to
assess how much progress.
I can only say progress,
because I have a goal in my mind
what do they need to reach
at the end of the course.
But how do I assess their
progress is a problem,
because some will start really
higher level than others.
So easier for me to see the
progress in the lower level
students.
Harder for me to see
the higher level.
So for me, the way I assess
is-- because I do have
a lot of writing assignments.
So I would see how much--
within an assignment,
how many new vocabulary
they're willing to use.
Because as I said, they like
to stay in their comfort zone.
They like to use
simple language.
They know it's correct.
They don't want to venture
out, because they're
afraid to make mistakes.
So my assessment usually
is how sophisticated
they can be when they're
doing the writing.
Because we have a set of
vocabulary for each lesson,
and they're supposed to use it.
And for me, because
they're assumed at a stage
they're still trying to
memorize all the characters,
trying to write
a basic sentence.
So the composition, I don't
ask too much of the structure.
As long as they can
write a sentence down,
the basic grammar's
correct, that's fine.
But the vocabulary they can use.
So and these vocabulary
sometimes in the course,
I would spend some
time to explain.
I don't teach them how
to read this vocabulary,
but I do correct
their pronunciation.
I do tell them how to
use this vocabulary.
Because some vocabulary,
they give you
the English definition,
but actually it
doesn't use that way
in Chinese at all.
Yes, this is what it means, but
you don't use the same context
in Chinese.
I would teach them
the differences.
That's what I talk about.
And I will some
students really want
to expand their vocabulary.
Then I will know he's trying.
That's how I assess
the progress.
We do have a lot of quizzes.
We do have a lot of tests.
We do have a lot of speaking.
We do a lot of individual
reports and group
projects in the classroom.
So all these I look
at holistically.
Yeah, yeah, I'm still thinking
about a more effective way
to assess them.
Especially I want the student
to do the self-assessment.
That's important.
They called it-- what's
that word-- anyway,
making a portfolio for
yourself, what you can do,
what you cannot do.
That kind of thing.
I started giving
them questionnaires,
but I want to develop more.
And to the last time
I did it, what can
I do now, what I know now.
Those are good, but
that's still very vague.
You have to ask the
right questions.
Sometimes it's all about
asking the right question.
Because some questions, they
can answer really vaguely.
Yes, I know, but how much
you really know, right?
So that's a big topic.
I'm still working on that.